the cards are shuffled
and the players get ready to begin a new
game
as well as luck they'll need to
accurately assess their opponent's
chances
to up their own odds a common strategy
is bluffing
both in poker and politics
my opponents don't know what cards i
have
i try to make them think i have the
stronger hand that may or may not be
true
it's a gamble with political parallels
spd leaders igma gabriel is a seasoned
player
his party is still considering whether
to seek another grand coalition with the
conservatives
the party will vote on it and gabriel
insists
they'll deal equally well with any
outcome
we're not afraid
is well aware that new elections could
backfire for the spd
but their show of strength and unity is
likely to put pressure on the
conservatives
upping the stakes
the trick is that neither party knows
how far the other side is prepared to go
that's the definition of taking a gamble
the main bone of contention between the
two parties is tax policy
the spd wants tax hikes for top earners
the conservatives don't
in the upcoming coalition talks that
could prove to be a deal breaker
on other issues their policies are more
compatible they both favor higher
pensions
benefits for stay-at-home parents
dual citizenship and a minimum wage in
some
sectors as the elections clear victors
chancellor angela merkel's conservatives
can choose their partner in government
but they do have to pick one and that's
easier said than done
the greens are also still in the game
but the parties would have to compromise
on similar issues
and the greens are currently very busy
dissecting their own problems
the party is in the process of
re-examining itself both in terms of
policy and personnel
that could further complicate coalition
talks with the conservatives
in poker the winner takes all that's
where the similarities with politics
end because building a coalition
involves give and take